[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Eric is
in Canada hi Eric welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hi there um thank you for Aon I
called you Eric I'm
sorry it's okay um I recently found the
Ramsey Show and enjoyed listening to it
even from Canada where I have to
mentally juggle the differences between
Canada and US Financial products sure
and I apologize in advance if I sound
confused I kind of am I'm really just
looking for Direction on what to do to
get a better sense of how my husband and
I are doing and what we should do next
but I think it's really just kind of to
get on the same page um as a new
listener I'm familiar with the baby
steps and I think that we're on four and
five um we both have my husband and I
both have jobs that we enjoy with
healthy salaries and index government
pensions we own our own house with a
mortgage that has considerable Equity we
have a rental house with a mortgage with
considerable Equity that's profitable
after tax we both have emergency funds
and we have um funds started for
Education funds for our children and in
addition to the work pension we both pay
into registered um our R rscs which is
Canada's version of a retirement um
registered retirement account with
automatic transfers um but despite all
that I feel like we're living paycheck
to paycheck and I'm always confused that
a family with the gross annual income of
over 250,000 it feels like we're just
getting by and I don't know if it's
because like how we're managing our
money or if it's just because we live in
a very expensive area in Vancouver um
but my husband and I have been together
for 14 years and married for nine and
we've always sort of kept our finances
separate and that's because we bought
our first house that's now our rental um
when we weren't married and um I know
it's not recommended from what I've
heard but we've kind of kept our
accounts separate and just combined it a
couple that we really needed to get by
um but I'm really just looking and I
think the next step is to kind of just
get back on the same page and um create
a plan for us and start doing monthly
meetings but I don't know how to start
that process and um I've always kind of
been the family CFO and uh I just need
to get like a better sense on how to
bring this up to him and some practical
steps on how to get on the same page for
the first time okay all right lot going
on here um thanks for the
outline um
now I'm trying to figure out like you
the core of this is when we do whatever
it is you're going to do combining
finances or any other moves that you
make the net result needs to be that you
get some peace because there's a lot of
strife and struggle
and scratching and clawing in this isn't
there well you know like I don't know I
don't know why we can't live on 250,000
and feel like we're not broke you said
it is it's so we look around and we're
like I feel like that's healthy and and
we see friends doing well and you know I
just always think like I wish I could
see what someone's bank account looked
like no you can't most of them most of
them are not being nearly as smart as
you are you've got your stuff dialed in
most of them are just living you have no
idea how screwed up they are their life
looks good it looks like it looks good
for a second on Instagram but if you
really got another the hood and make you
puke um yeah yeah so I tell my husb I my
husband that's exactly right I promise
you I pull up at a stoplight I see a
nice car now I don't see a nice car I
see
payments yeah that fool's got a $1,250
payment that's what runs through my head
um I used to see a nice car now I see a
fool but um the uh um anyway the yeah I
I think you need to sit down with him
and say Hey you know we've done it this
way 14 years it's passable but I feel
like I'm holding this together I feel
like I got all 10 fingers stuck in the
Dyke and it's I'm and it still feels
like water's getting over me and I
really want to combine these things so
that I don't mind doing the execution of
our plan but I'm tired of developing the
plan by
myself and I want us to combine things
and you and I make a a group of basic
decisions on what we're going to do with
our money lay out a budget each month uh
where we know where every dollar is
going to go we both agree to it and then
I'll do the execution I I doubt he wants
to or would relish taking over the
Tactical paying of the bills which you
kind of actually enjoy
probably uh I I think I like having
control of it um yeah and I think that
there's like a level of trust too or
like I I would I would worry about
relinquishing that and I think that
that's why I've always kind of wanted
relinquishing the
trust or relinquishing the power sorry
that's fair of of you know knowing it
all hour comes the
stress yeah and that's probably what's
putting the strain on you that's what
I'm saying I I'm I listen I'm I'm
America's Financial nerd right so don't
you know I do this stuff and I and I you
know my opinion between Sharon and I
carries a lot of weight uh but we don't
do anything unless she's in alignment
first and then that helps me because
we're emotionally carrying the decisions
of our giving emotionally carrying the
decisions of our investing or our big
decisions to get together and then I'll
go do the execution of it it it becomes
a no-brainer and that also prevents I
told you
so um I knew you were G to screw that up
you know well Shar Sharon could tell say
I told you so it could happen at my
house and it doesn't happen CU she can't
she was in on it you know if something
screws up it's like we screwed that up
not like I I knew you were going to mess
that up you know that doesn't come up at
my house hasn't in 30 years so it's
really nice I like it so um I got a
question Erin because I'm listening to
this back and forth here and you you
said that you that I thought I heard you
say that you and your husband both have
a emergency funds is that correct sure
yeah is that three to six months on each
side between the two of you uh no not
each side combined together it would be
that but um when I think if we both lost
our job at the same time that would not
be great but and you're both investing
or you're com you're both investing 15%
or you're combining investing 15 no we
both we both have um government funded
pensions do you have any other debt
besides the
mortgages no none yeah I think it'd be
really cool to dream together again too
to dream together in high definition
about okay we can if if we could find
some money in this $250,000 budget what
would be fun for us to do what investing
would we do would we pay off the house
would we pay off the rental would we uh
do some additional generosity and making
those decisions together rather than
just running this like it's a joint
venture um I think you're going to find
a whole new depth to your relationship I
don't think you've got a horrible
marriage uh but I think you could I
think I think you're going to find it
being better when you combine matter of
fact I know from working with millions
of people talking them into this and
it's amazing the number of people that
hate us for telling people to combine
their finances but whatever uh we're
right and you're wrong so you ought to
do it um really I mean it works it
changes your marriage forces you to
dream together it forces you to carry
the weight together it forces you to
communicate about purchase decisions and
for God's sake where we're going to go
for Christmas this year your mother's
house or my mother's house it has to
it's in the budget we have to talk about
you can't just there's no surprises
there's no side agendas it's like this
Unity thing and uh it creates a Unity a
level of unity that nothing else will do
so hey here's the thing what what if you
combined it all and tried it a year and
I was wrong and you absolutely hated it
well you didn't lose any
money just split it back apart what's
wrong with trying it that's what IID do
give it a shot and ask tell him that too
just say hey what if if it doesn't work
if we hate it we can always split it
back apart it's not like a tattoo I mean
we can change it right there's a lot of
stuff we can do here so it's not a
permanent fixture